hey youtubers is charlie so Game of
Thrones episode 4 is tonight but we've
actually learned the titles from episode
6 and 7 so this is going to be an
explainer for what those are and a
little bit of speculation just careful
for spoilers for everything that's
happened this season so far the timeline
right now tonight's episode 4 is book of
the stranger episode 5 is titled the
door episode 6 is titled blood of my
blood which it sounds very Denarius
eccentric which we'll talk about in a
second episode 7 is supposedly called
the broken man so I'll let you think
about that while we get started so blood
of my blood that is a very Dothraki
saying making it sound like Daenerys is
going to start to make her move maybe
we'll see this drogon scene from the
trailer the phrase is mostly used by
blood writers whose part of like a
Dothraki cows entourage they're a bit of
a guardian something of a brother like
the closest bond that you could possibly
have to someone you are not physically
related to so think of it as a more
honorable version of becoming someone's
Kingsguard only a Cal can ask someone to
become his blood rider and he says I ask
your oath that will live and die as
blood of my blood riding at my side to
keep me safe from harm so if a cow dies
the blood writer is supposed to follow
him into death so would it not be
awesome if we had a scene where Daenerys
is taking her own blood riders it's so
early in the season I don't know if they
would do that that quickly but because
jon snow came back from the dead so
quickly it's possible they could just be
speeding things along if Dan and Dave
are saying there's maybe only like
thirteen episodes after season six then
it's totally possible Daenerys could
gain the loyalty of the Dothraki and
deal with slavers Bay in time for the
end of season six during book one after
Khal Drogo dies de nurse asks three
Dothraki to become her blood riders they
all refuse her until her dragons are
hatched then like everyone at the site
of dragons they all [ __ ] their pants and
swear fealty to her so she has had blood
riders this whole time in the books but
the TV show hasn't really done them as
much so this might be there a way of
doing that but right now she's envious
Dothrak at this giant Congress of the
Dothraki people's so what would be more
amazing to watch than dinners winning
the fealty of the entire Dothraki people
even if she doesn't officially become a
cow because she's part of their society
she could probably try to take new blood
riders
not necessarily expecting it but a
really awesome twist would be of calmora
person who just takes an absolute dump
on her in the first episode becomes one
of her new blood riders let's move on to
episode 7 this is going to be fun so
just speculation the title the broken
man might be a reference to the Hound
coming back this might be what ian
mcshane was talking about so I know a
lot of you really want to see Clegane
Bowl Circe was hinting at a trial with
the faith Jamie got really excited at
the thought of seeing zombie Mountain
fight in a trial with the faith I'm
gonna drop a couple f-bombs here so just
fair warning what would be more amazing
than if there's a trial for the faith
zombie mountain walks out so she's
feeling like she's invincible and then
the faith trots the Hound out and he
just says [ __ ] the king in thomond just
shits his pants so if there is gonna be
a trial we might not see it till the
very end of the series but let me know
in the comments do you think the title
the broken man is all about the Hound
coming back there have been a couple
pieces of supporting evidence most of
the evidence from the TV show this
season is just in support of a trial
with the faith not necessarily the Hound
coming back other than the way Arya
talked about him in past tense when she
was playing the game of faces the real
supporting evidence is ian mcshane
talking about having this really minor
one-off role is that he's responsible
for bringing back a character that
everybody thinks is dead he said he
leads a piece cult which sounds
amazingly like what happens with Brienne
on the quiet I'll during feast for crows
at that point in the books brain was
still traveling around the Riverlands
looking for the stark children her
travels took her to the quiet Isle she
comes upon a person named the elder
brother and then you learn about this
person called the gravedigger that
sounds mysteriously like the hound and
she just happens to see a horse that
looks like the horse that the Hound road
so a lot of people just believe that the
hound has been convalescing at this
quiet Isle place he's found religion
he's given up his aggressive ways so
because he's so religious now that's why
a lot of people think that the faith
might choose him if he were to come back
so that's very possible that we might
see him for the first time again in
episode 7 but like I said at this point
in the books Bryan was doing a lot of
different things but we see her in the
Riverlands here with the toll a banner
so she's going to be in the Riverlands
later this season for some reason so
we'll just have to watch for the next
couple of episodes but be listening to
things that characters say that might
imply that the Hound is coming back so
what's going to happen tonight is I'll
post my episode for video book of
stranger it'll be really fun to talk
about that I'll talk about the faith of
the seven because that's one of the
aspects of the seven but be sure to
subscribe to get that there is a new
round of the giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video it's just a
twenty-dollar amazon gift card and it'll
stay open till I post my Q&A video next
week why you guys wait for that video to
post tonight you can click here for my
episode 3 video from last week and you
can click here to learn more about the
prince who as promised or + l equals J
all that awesome stuff so thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight